Hi everyone, welcome. Thank you for
joining us this morning. Um, my name is
Amy Boyd. I lead our foundry developer
relations team at Microsoft. I'm joined
by my colleague Nitia on the team who is
an absolute expert in observability. And
today we thought we'd have a nice catchy
title uh given where we are in London of
Mind the Gap in your agent
observability. We'll talk a little bit
through what we actually mean by mind
the gap because it's got a deeper reason
than just the nice sort of uh title
there, but also we'll start going
through some really interesting stuff
and you'll have a load of assets to take
away with you as well. Um this area is
there's a lot there's so much to cover
in the agent space even just in
observability itself. So, we'll we'll
get you kickarted, but there'll be a
journey afterwards that you can take as
well if we, you know, uh, get you
excited about what we've got going on
here.
So, uh, mind the gap is a actually a
really good terminology for
observability when you look at agents
specifically. Um, one of the interesting
things Nitia realized is she started her
journey uh in New York and found it's
also mind notap watch the gap whereas
it's minds the gap here but when we
started to really think a little bit
more deeply about it actually works
super well with an observability
analogy. So if you think about um things
like when we evaluate an agent we're
checking for like the quality and the
change over time that an agent goes
through. And if you think about the
change in trains and technology, but the
platform doesn't change. So there's this
sign on there because at each station
it's different. The train might fit
perfectly like this one here, brand new
train designed beautifully for said
platform, but in other cases there's a
wide gap between the requirements, which
is the platform, and the actual agent,
which is the train in this case. And so
what we want to talk a little bit about
is how you can run evaluations from
very, very early on. and throughout the
life cycle in order to bring your
requirements to the reality of what your
agent is actually doing in the wild.
There's another element of this mind the
gap analogy that works so well as well
which is actually when you start
thinking a bit more about safety. The
reason these signs are in place, they
are guard rails at the end of the day
for your uh for the tube. In this case,
it says mine the gap. is letting your
customers know that there's something
that you need them to do to be careful
of. And it's the same thing when we
apply things like guard rails and safety
mechanisms inside agents and monitor
exactly how customers are engaging with
your agent. And then finally, the
monitoring side. These things, these
platforms, these change change over
time. And so having the constant
reminder of the phrasing mind the gap
over the tanoi allows people to remind
themselves as customers that this is
happening. But on the monitoring side as
a developer with agents you also need to
know what's happening not just today but
consistently across many agents
potentially that you're building in the
future. So by the end of this session we
want you to be able to say what is the
gap between agent observability and what
you're actually building. How do we mind
that gap? And we'll give you lots of
different opportunities to think about
the ways that you plan for and implement
minding the gap around observability.
And also, how do we accelerate that
optimize loop? So, how do we say from
the information I'm actually given with
all of this data, what do I do with it
next in order to improve my agents over
time?
So today we're going to have lots and
lots of great assets, but what we want
to do is break down everything into
small chunks so that we can kind of keep
progressing forward. Um, first things
first, we'd love for you to fork the
repo. We've got a wonderful GitHub
repository. We've been working on it for
quite a while. It's something that we've
been updating and we will continuously
do so as well. So this is going to be a
great asset to take with you in the
future as we add new elements over time.
We also have uh a Discord channel that's
specifically for our our Microsoft
Foundry users. Uh we've actually created
an AI engineer channel. We'd love to see
you in there. Um what we're going to do
today is kind of get through quite a lot
of stuff as you take this GitHub
repository away. What we want you to do
is continue to engage with us. Me and
Nitia spend a lot of time in that
Discord server. Uh and we'd love to be
able to chat you through and help you
along this journey as well as you start
using um all of these different assets.
So as you just take along. So we've got
some short links but also some QR codes
if you want to use them.
So just very quickly as we get started
into what technology we're going to use
today. I know we asked a few of you uh
as you get started the different things
that you're using. This is the the
reality of the agent space which is many
people are using lots of different
technologies. But at the end of the day
we use this phrase agents are
non-deterministic. That's not just a
problem for demos. That's also a problem
for real life when you actually get to
production. And the reliability and
consistency is starting to become when
you start passing this out to customers,
you need to be managing the
non-determinism that comes inside those
agents.
And three ways that we we see as to do
that kind of reliability is one to
evaluate to look at performance, look at
quality and safety. Um and also consider
kind of how well your agent is
performing. looking at monitoring. So,
not just when you're building, not just
as an add-on situation with evaluations,
but actually monitoring your agents over
time as the requirements change, as the
customers change, as the environment
changes is super important to know how
you continuously improve and debug any
issues that come up quickly. And then
finally, that optimize section. And so
optimizing your agents performance,
taking all of this incredible data that
we're starting to be able to get from
agents and actually doing something with
it as well. Um, we can tell you, you
know, all sorts of different scores and
stuff like that, but it's that next
step, but what do I do now? And we've
got some really fascinating stuff that
we can show you there.
We'll focus on a specific platform.
Myself and Nitia work with Microsoft
Foundry. Uh it's our cloud agent
platform for all your endto-end
opportunities with agents. So you can
build the agents, but if you're building
the agents elsewhere, you can also host
the agents, observe the agents, and
manage and monitor your agents within
that same platform of offering. You can
use as much or as little as you wish. Uh
some of the things that we'll notice
around observability is they come across
three different phases. You should be
having observability built in at a
really really early stage as you're
building your agents. So we'll kick off
in that early stage. You'll look at what
you can do when you debug and optimize
in production and then also when we
start thinking in the future it may not
be uh that far in the future for those
in the room which is actually how we
managing many agents not just even not
just even multi- aent systems but
actually many many multi- aent systems
as well.
So a couple of areas we'll talk through
today uh are things like tracing in
those early stages. So thinking about um
how you can actually access all of the
monitor and debugging information from
your agent. What is it actually doing?
What tools is it calling? What com um
what different messages is it sending to
all of the different steps in your agent
workflows. One of the really nice things
about um tracing in foundry is actually
we build on the hotel um offering and so
the the group here at Microsoft actually
do a lot of work to work with that
standard and think about what it looks
like for agents in the future as well.
We'll continue to do that which actually
then opens up the ability for you. You
don't have to build everything in one
place. you actually may be using
different things uh to build different
agents across an organization or across
many businesses and that's absolutely
fine. You can actually bring all of
those agents and instrument them uh with
hotel tracing which means you can then
manage them inside the foundry control
plane. Oh, there we go. We're back. Um
the next one is at that build stage
you're going to look at evaluators. Um,
it almost feels like a little bit of an
eyesaw. Uh, this uh slide's got a lot on
it, but I think take that from it.
There's so many built-in evaluators from
being able to build agents at scale.
We're obviously learning a lot as a
platform provider as to what customers
need. And so then we start to embed that
into the platform itself. You'll notice
and probably be very familiar with a lot
of the quality metrics. risk and safety
is something that often comes as like a
second thought but should be built in in
those um inside those agents. And then
we've kind of started to move quite
quickly from um evaluating the model and
the actually large language model itself
to evaluating the agent output as well.
And so the agent specific evaluators are
the ones to really consider there as we
start to think it's not just that one
engagement with the LLM. It's actually
how does the agent do holistically
across its time and its workflow. Um but
if some of these evaluators aren't
working for your scenario, that's
absolutely fine because you can actually
build your own custom evaluators and use
the best of both worlds in that
situation.
And so what do we mean when we kind of
evaluate across the agent um workflow is
to actually take um weather's the usual
great example isn't it of um we're in
London it's often unusual weather today
it's actually beautiful weather um so
you're a weather agent that's a system
message our user says what's the weather
in London today first evaluation that we
might want to do is actually the intent
resolution one. So we would say does the
user uh the user wants to know the local
weather has it been able to understand
that intent and then make the next
decision point that it needs to which is
make a tool call. Then once we get to
the tool call space you should evaluate
the tool call itself. Um there's a whole
set of metrics you could kind of do
within that space including just
operational metrics in general. But at
that point you want to say is the tool
call the expected one? um in the
majority of cases again that
non-determinism does mean that we will
be working with percentages there. And
then finally the overall response. So
that's at that agent level of actually
how well did it do on task completion.
Um how the task adurance one tends to be
the one that is the one that you need
kind of tweak I would say over time. But
this shows where it's not just
evaluating once. You can evaluate a many
many different parts of your agent life
cycle so that when do things do start to
go wrong or aren't quite the top quality
you're expecting, you can go and
pinpoint exactly where you can make
those changes.
We have a few extra elements that we uh
hopefully will get to today. it very
quickly. Uh we mentioned a little bit
that actually debugging multi- aent
traces becomes exponentially more
difficult than just those uh smaller
agent specific calls. So there's loads
of great ways that we're building that
into the platform so you can look at a
full agent trace and not just the agent
itself uh any single agent at one time.
But we're also offering quite a lot of
work that goes into monitoring those
agents across many different dimensions.
So whether that's uh continuous
evaluations that happening when you're
changing codes, scheduled evaluations
that you're working on, uh red teaming,
so things like security you're adding in
or also if you're already using
monitoring across your cloud estate, you
may want to pull in some of that
information uh around the agent as well.
But the key thing here is again on that
observability side. If you're already
using things like a monitoring solution
in the cloud, we have Azure monitor for
your infrastructure and your data. The
AI platform allows you to bring in the
foundry control plane stuff we'll see
today, but actually connect to Azure
monitor in the end. So developers build
with what you wish and your IT admins
will still be very very happy because
it'll integrate.
And then finally on that fleetwide
control as we start to look a little bit
more into the future, it's kind of
looking at that centralized
observability looking across far more
than just one multi- aent system and
understanding what your fleet looks like
with inside either the business or um or
your own kind of business that you're
building and actually all of your
different agents. So I know we had many
different hosting off opportunities in
the room and we've discussed and so this
is a great way to think about how we can
build in bring in agents from anywhere
but again observe within the fleet view
there
and then finally security. We won't
actually get loads of time to touch on
security today, which is really sad
because it's so impressive um what we're
looking at for security in the agent
space at the moment. Um but I highly
recommend going and checking out a lot
of the work we do around red teaming. Um
red teaming is not something you do
alone. And so Microsoft um works a lot
with the pirate um open-source
repository and does a lot of uh deep
engagement in order to help improve open
source and offer a lot of our stuff open
source, but we also have kind of the
one-click options inside the platform as
well.
So we spoke a little bit about the
foundry control plane. We're only going
to cover observability in any kind of
depth today um in our short time with
you. However, there is a lot more to
offer and so we just want to make sure
that you take that information away with
you. So, at that point, I'm going to
pass on to Nitia who's going to talk a
little bit more about the workshop setup
that we're going to do.
>> Awesome. Thanks, Amy.
>> All right. Um, get your keyboard fingers
ready. So, let's try to get uh into
this. So, what I want to basically tell
you, how many of you think you can
basically learn everything you want to
learn in the next 30 minutes? This is
not the workshop for you. So, I want to
set the stage by saying this repo is
actually almost like a 4-hour workshop
that we're trying to compress into this.
So, what I want you to think about is
this is a cooking show. I'm going to
show you the baked goods, but I want you
to look at the repo because it has
everything and you can then try this at
home and inject your own stuff and
actually play with it. It's the only way
you learn. So, to set the stage, we're
going to have a use case, right? So, how
many of you have built multi- aent
applications already? Awesome. How many
of you are completely new to this and
want to just know how to get started?
Awesome. This is exactly the kind of
audience we're looking for. So let's say
this, you've just joined a company
called Contoso. Contoso is a very famous
fiction fictiticious company in
Microsoft. Your boss comes and says, "I
need you to build this travel agent
application, right? Where do you start?"
So let's first kind of set the stage for
what an agent is. We all know models,
right? Everyone's worked with AI models.
You get a sense of it. What does the
agent do? Models when they're born, they
have a certain amount of knowledge.
Agents allow you to bring in additional
knowledge and capabilities through tools
to enhance the existing model. The
models are the brains. The agent is kind
of like the experience and the tools are
all the things that you put in to make
sure that the model's enhanced. So when
you think about this, I'm building a
travel agent. What do I need? I need to
know what the instructions are for that
agent. What is it supposed to do? I need
to know what tools do I need to make
sure that it can actually execute them.
And I need to have the right model for
the job. Make sense?
Where do I start? The problem for us is
anyone want to guess how many models
there are on hugging face right now?
>> No, no, no. Two plus million.
Anyone want to guess how many Azure has
in our catalog?
>> 11,000 plus. Okay. I can't if you show
me three jams, I can't pick one. You
show me 11,000 models, I have no clue
where to start. Right? So, what we're
really looking at is when you start the
job of building an application, you
don't want to make all these decisions.
How do you just get quickly started?
Right? So, here is the challenge from a
developer perspective. Bar says, "Hey, I
need you to build a travel agent that
helps the user find the right hotel,
car, and thing. What do you do?"
Challenge number one, too many models. I
have no existing data. This app never
existed before. Where do I get the data
to even do evals, right? So, we're going
to show you how you can solve that. So,
how do I go from zero to agent prototype
with minimal knowledge? Second, AI
quality. This is a brand that your
company has. If your agent does
something to destroy it, that comes back
to you. So, how can you detect issues in
your agent, diagnose and fix them really
quickly? So, that's what the quality
solution is. And finally, safety,
safeguarding it. The difference between
the second and the third is that the
second assumes that your users are
acting normally. The third says, I have
a malicious user who's going to try to
prompt attack my my my solution. How do
I protect against it? The analogy I'll
give you is if you're building a home.
The second one is evaluations where
you've got a building inspector who
comes and checks you're up to code. But
safeguarding is like calling the guy and
saying can you break into my house
please so I can sh I can be proved that
this is working and then tell me all the
ways in which I fail. Right? So that's
the big difference. Make sense?
>> Am I moving too fast? My speed. Okay.
That's the number one feedback I always
get. Too fast. Okay. So before I go in,
I'm going to switch over and tell you
where to start. So what I want you to do
is I want you to go to the
repo.
So you all were given uh the kind of
like the link to it. If you don't have
it handy, I will show you where it is
right now. You can grab it right off the
screen if you zoom in. But what I want
you to do, you are not going to be able
to do everything today. What I want you
to do is fork the repo and show you how
to jump start your development
environment so that you can at least
follow along. You will need an an Azure
account and a GitHub account. What I
will tell you is you can get away with
using a free Azure account. There will
be a small cost. I've been running this
for two days. It's about 10 bucks. But
if you join the Discord, we're going to
see if we can actually get a few
resources that will help you later. So
you can try this at home. But for now,
you need just go ahead and fork the
repo, right? Uh, everyone good with
that? Yes. So, what I'm going to do is
I've already forked the repo, but once
you fork the repo, what I want you to do
is when you fork the repo, please
uncheck the main so that you're getting
all the branches. The reason is we've
been doing this workshop at different
places and so it'll keep evolving. You
want to fork it with our with all
branches so you can get the AIE Europe
branch which is the current mind the
observer mind the gap uh kind of
workshop.
And one of the reasons for this is at
the end of this I will merge this back
into main and we'll have yet another
workshop in a month which will have even
more stuff and then we'll park that
again. Right? So by forking this I want
you to look at this workshop today and
then keep an eye on the repo tomorrow.
Is everyone good? All right. The next
thing you're going to do is in your
branch and I've already done this but
what you're going to do is in the in
your branch on GitHub if you click this
code you should have logged in right? Uh
how many here have used code spaces?
Yes, my people. So, for those of you who
don't know, one of the biggest problems
when you want to do development is to
set up your environment. You have to
install the packages, do all the stuff,
right? Um, code spaces uses a concept
called dev containers. You'll see that
the repo has this dev container. And
what the dev container does is it
basically defines everything, all the
dependencies that you need. And what
codes spaces does is effectively uh when
I basically start this off and run a
code space. If I say just start me a new
code space, it will start up an instance
of a VM in the cloud on this container
and give me the environment all set up.
So you don't have to install any tools,
packages installed, everything is ready
to go. So I'm just showing you you saw
how that was set up. So if you did that
and you have to wait a few minutes for
it to be ready, but this is a cooking
show. So this is how I start. Then I
want to seamlessly move to the cooked
code space. Okay. But now you've seen uh
is everyone good so far? Um it's very
dark I know but um let me see if I can
switch the
>> this repos on our um on our Azure
organization on GitHub and so uh we will
take all the costs. This won't go into
your code spaces costs as well. So it's
um it's quite nice when you are able to
use sort of those things with inside
organizational repos because it actually
goes onto the enterprise account
instead. So yeah uh nice little freebie
there as well for compute time. So if
you were to start that up and you saw I
just started it. It'll take a while.
So I'm going to let you all just let it
run and we're going to switch back and
look at the cooked version. Tada.
Okay. So what is code spaces? What you
basically get is a VS Code instance
that's running in your browser. This VS
Code instance is connected to a running
container in the cloud that has all the
the the the tools and your dependencies
installed. More importantly, on the
side, you will actually see I'm going to
reduce this font just for a second so
you can see everything. You will see
that we have a bunch of tools installed
out of the box. And so what these do for
you is they give you additional features
that you can use when we're basically
going to try out things like running
notebooks, things like a skill that'll
automate all your stuff for you. So once
you're here, I want to point out two
things
in that repo that you just uh so when
you're going and doing this at home, if
you go follow through, there are
actually two paths and we're going to
try to cover them really quickly today.
Path one is the traditional path. It's
the SDK path. I recommend it for
everyone who is new. Go through it and
get a sense step by step. We're going to
cover it a little bit. Path two is for
people who think, hey, I want to
actually use a coding agent and take it
for a spin. In the second path, you will
just build that blank agent endpoint and
then turn the skill loose on that
endpoint and it'll start helping you
build out the stuff and evaluate it
automatically. We'll look at both today.
So, here's the application scenario.
We're building a travel agent that has a
car rental, a a hotel, and a a flight
agent built into it. Here's the workshop
outline. All you need to know is there
are four steps. Step one is what you
just did, the infrastructure setup. Uh
we basically want to go I'm I'm going to
hand it over to Amy to do that. You've
got your code spaces running. That's the
dev environment setup. We'll come to
that in a minute. Code spaces takes a
little while. So I'm going to switch it
over to Amy. And what we're going to do
now is step one, we're going to go and
set up that dumb agent, a simple starter
agent in Foundry that will do the travel
thing for you. Amy, do you want to take
over?
>> And if you want to actually see the one
that's already done, it is over here.
>> Awesome. Let me close this. And the code
spaces here.
>> Okay.
>> Um, so yeah, I will do our initial sort
of stance. So, um, we all love code here
and we get very excited when we can kind
of like dip in and out of an SDK and
stuff like that, but realistically that
first starting point, um, highly
recommend just hanging out in the portal
a little bit and just taking some of
this stuff for a test drive very very
quickly. And so, what I'll show you is
that quick pace. How do I briefly build
an agent, but think about tracing emails
right from the the word go in some
senses. So, um, Microsoft Foundry is
just at ai.asure.com. azure.com um on on
the internet. It's part of obviously the
Azure cloud. Um so if you already have
Azure set up, you should be able to get
very very quick access to that. Um and
then one thing you'll notice is there's
actually this like new Microsoft Foundry
experience that we're looking at. And so
if you click start building just here,
you can actually create uh very quickly
a new project. We'll call this one
London and theno.
And what you'll see here is it creates
you a project, a resource. It chooses
your subscription. So the usual cloud
kind of pieces, a resource group, and
actually one of the things that we're
going to do is is change this to a
recommended region, which is actually
East US2 at the moment with some of our
newest newest stuff. uh and click
create. So this will head off and just
create you the most basic foundry
project. It'll then uh initiate things
like models and we'll very quickly start
building an agent. But a project is a
space that you can come and have agents
with inside a single project uh that you
obviously you can evaluate and trace
across all of them as well. So we'll
take a little look as that as it gets
started. Um, one of the interesting
things around Foundry is actually just
that setup piece. We have worked done
quite a lot of work to just get those
initial stages but also still be able to
have the ability to say actually I want
to customize as well very very quickly.
And so we'll see that it'll do a lot for
us so that we can start but then you'll
be able to move on and just really you
know envision your whole new piece
yourself. Um, so you'll get a nice
little opening here. This is kind of
exactly experience you'll see.
And then we'll get taken straight away
to create our first agent. Like the
platform is to build agents. So let's uh
let's do that. So we'll go Ktoso Travel
is our agent. Um, and we'll give it a
name that won't be in there. So you will
need to give it a unique name. What
you'll notice here is it's saying it's
deploying GPT41. So, it's just looking
for capacity straight away for you. Um,
and it's finding you a very very quick
model and then we're straight into the
playground. Um, 41 obviously being, you
know, a decent model model of your
choice is also available in the catalog,
but again, a great way to start.
Playgrounds, we're all very uh versed, I
think, at this point with playgrounds.
You have things like voice mode. You can
switch on uh simple agent instructions.
add your different tools. So, in this
case, we're actually going to add a web
search, um, which will just be our Bing
search because we're obviously wanting
to create a travel agent, so we needed
to go and look at Expedia and all that
kind of good stuff. Um, and then under
here, you'll notice we do have this
model, but we also obviously promote
other models. And then you can click
browse models and see all the providers,
uh, whether it's Anthropic, Deep Seek,
um, etc., etc., all all of those,
they're all in there. Um, one of the
interesting things we can obviously
initially start engaging
um
with our agent, but this agent is just a
generic model at this point. There's no
instructions, there's no nothing, and
we've just got some web search. So,
it'll kind of go away and it'll tell us
it can do basically most things,
including general advice for us. So,
that's not what we want in this case.
So, what I'm going to do is go to my
nice pre-baked one. We'll save that
agent
and we'll go and take a little look.
>> Oh um one other thing is you've got to
actually create um app insights. So the
agent by itself right now is not
traceable right like it's just there.
It's been created but you want to make
sure it's always picking up things. So
the foundry portal is a great way for
you to get really a quick start. So if
you sorry Amy I forgot to mention that
>> back to the other one. Yeah, if you go
into the one that she just created, all
you have to do is select that agent,
click on the traces tab, and it'll say
you don't have app insights, and if you
go through that right now, and Amy, I
don't know if you want to do that or
not. Flip over.
>> I was going to say that. So, um, being
able to click on this, you can then add
App Insights as a connector tool with
inside the admin portal. Very, very
quickly. Um, one of the other nice
pieces is there's actually an agent
helper just up here on the right. So you
could say how do I connect my app
insights and it'll talk you through
exactly step by step how to do it as
well. Um but yeah very very quick easy
way. App insights is a technology that
does all sorts of tracing prior to
agents being a realism for us. And so
that would be a very quick way for us to
kind of turn that piece on as well.
So let me show you something where it's
got a little bit more to it. So uh back
into our traces as we start to use that.
So, as we start to engage, we'll start
to see the traces as well as the
conversations land here with um
estimated cost, tokens, the usual
things, but also even things like
evaluations.
We've added some instructions here just
so of what our Ktoso agent actually
does. So, one of the interesting ones is
like always use the web search, um
always have a comparison, present
externally source specific. So add some
of those uh elements that people can see
where it's grounded on as well. Um and
keep responses focused and helpful, that
type of thing. We've got our web search.
Uh one other thing is to check out the
configuration because what you'll notice
here is you can actually add things like
display name, description. So if I head
over to
>> I think if you flip to version two,
you'll see it there. We're now in the
version that
we love a little version control.
Ah, no problem.
So, all of your different steps are in
this repo. So, we've done a lot of this
piece. We've created our project. We go
down to create our agent. We're in the
playground. We add the app insights.
We can test our agent in the playground
with different prompts.
But we can also add these different
configuration properties. And then the
outcome of adding some details there
starts to bring back your travel
assistant with the usual stuff like what
is it that people can do with it? those
easy step by steps that give them the
ability to quickly start engaging with
your agent without it being like,
"Hello, what do you do?" That kind of
command at the start and then having to
move from there. Um, so you can kind of
very very quickly build um
up your travel portal
as you start to engage. Let me grab um
that query again from just over here.
Again, you can use all of this stuff
that we've provided in here.
Copy this one
and send that off.
We'll send that. It should come back
with some of those grounded responses.
um
information on car rentals etc. But one
of the interesting things here I just
wanted to highlight is actually the
elements at the bottom. So it tells you
what model it used if you're using
something like a router. That would be
more interesting because you would be
able to see given the query which model
it actually chose to use things like
tokens but you'll also see straight away
that we've actually got an AI quality
and an AI safety metric that are under
here. And so one of the pieces uh you're
able to do is under metrics just at the
top here is you can very quickly just
tick these different things on. So as I
said like starting in the portal means
don't have to think about what all of
the different names are for all these
different things. You can just get
acquainted with what's available and
built in and then you can very quickly
start to visualize exactly how that
might look. And all of us immediately
then leap to code right in the sense
that we go okay I I get it. I get that
we've got these built-in things. How
would I do it with the SDK? So, with all
of them then selected, you can head off
to things like the tracing logs. You can
see exactly what steps and messages it
took. And then inside the input and
output, you've got an evaluations tab.
And so, it then evaluates and gives you
some responses back on all of the
different evaluations that you've
actually selected. So, again, this one's
an interesting one. Little warning. task
adurance is actually quite low for what
we were asking. It didn't really
actually answer the question that I
wanted it to. It kind of said, "Oh, give
me more information." And so, this bit
is obviously there when you can start to
really think about, okay, how do I start
to go from from zero because we're at
the most simple agent at this point, but
we're already able to get those
evaluation results against it. So in
this setup, I basically just wanted to
show you that I can go from nothing and
create a project, an agent with a model
that's just a default, add some
instructions on a web search, start to
engage so I can see those traces, select
some evaluation metrics so I can see
some evaluations in those early stages.
And then from here, I'd probably want to
start thinking, okay, now I've got sort
of a very quick proof of concept. I want
to start moving to code. And so from
here I'll pass on to Nitia who will
start moving into the code.
>> Awesome. Thanks Amy.
>> So uh before I switch over to that um
just a quick show of hands. How many of
you are familiar with tracing? How many
of you familiar with evals? How many you
are familiar with most of the quality,
safety and agentic eval types. Okay. So
we'll try to go into a little bit on
that. How many of you have written a
custom evaluator?
Prompt or code?
Prompt. Prompt. Okay. So one of the
things I wanted to kind of just to wrap
the thing before we move into the code
space is the main reason this is super
important is if you think about the
notion of observability it's not enough
for you to know when things go wrong.
You need to shorten the time between
detecting something went wrong and
diagnosing it. So trace linked
evaluations are where it's at. So, one
of the things that I just want to
highlight before we move back in here is
that when you look at this, what what
Amy was showing is every time you see a
trace, if you've actually linked the
evaluations correctly, they will show up
here. And that means that you can look
at the ULS and figure out what part of
the trace as an example. Say your model
changed and you had to put a new model
in. Suddenly, you find that your tool
calls are no longer as efficient. Your
evals are going to tell you your tool I
mean your one of those metrics failed.
But now you can come back into the
traces and say what was different
between this version and the previous
version. And we'll see that through the
coding skill later. If you compare them
you'll be like oh wait one of the tools
didn't get called. Why? Right? So you're
able to move quickly to actually compare
what happened which is the detection
with the diagnosis. All right. Uh let's
now move to code. So we've built
ourselves a very simple agent right
through the portal. Now it we want to
actually do something more complex. So
what I want you to do is in the in your
kind of like we did lab 00 we set this
up development environment you all
started a code space you don't have to
do that right now but when you go home
what you're going to do is when you log
into Azure and set up that foundry
project you've got your infra set up but
you need your code spaces to now be
connected to the infra the code the the
the repository has a very simple script
run the script what it's going to do is
it's going to use the Azure developer
Azure CLI to go and get all the required
information and set up avoid
run notebooks. So it'll kind of take
away some of that uh issues for you. The
other thing you're going to do is there
is something called an AI toolkit
extension. We won't go into it right
now, but what it is is equivalent to
having that Foundry UI right in VS Code.
So you can see some of the things you're
doing. So you're going to check that
off. And long story short, by the time
you're done, you now have your
development environment set up to talk
to the infrastructure that you just
deployed. And we can now go on into our
codebased approach. So I'm actually
going to go into the SDK approach first.
So let me kind of show you why.
So we did the plan in portal and when
you looked at the portal this is what
the actual end toend development life
cycle for an agent actually looks like.
You need to have a build phase. Then you
need to optimize it and then you need to
deploy and govern it. So when you think
about all the steps involved in build
we're going to start by what we did in
the portal is I knew my use case. It's a
travel agent. Quickly developed my
models tools and a simple agent for it.
I tested a prompt. I built it. I was
able to get all of that done. I added a
simple web search tool. Now I have an
agent working that's grounded in things
I wanted grounded in. We're not going to
talk about fine-tuning, but we really
want to go to the next day of I want to
be able to like do more complicated
things with this. So to go to the SDK,
we're going to focus on showing you how
to do all of these in code. So what
you're going to do here is go back to
the code spaces that you started
and cooking demo. So, tada. I've got my
code spaces there. Um, I'm not going to
show you my end because it actually has
my keys in it, but just know that it was
set up. Uh, when you run the script, uh,
it'll actually set this up right here.
And what you now do is you're going to
work through these labs in order. So,
I'm going to start with the first one.
And if you are familiar with VS Code at
all, what don't know how many of you,
everyone here familiar with Jupyter
notebooks?
Yes. Okay. Do you know about this little
outline tab? I love it. So, what I would
do is say that as you go through these,
uh, you'll notice that the labs I'm
going to first tell you what they are
and then you can kind of on each lab I
expect you to just flip it into the
outline mode and then we'll go through
them. So, what do we have? The story
that we're going to tell is top to
bottom. First, the first lab is
basically going to run and make sure
that your development environment is
connected to your backend with a simple
test prompt. Everything's working. The
next lab is you're going to rebuild your
first agent in code. In other words, you
built it in the portal declaratively.
This notebook will give you all the code
snippets you need to build it
programmatically. So you can use that
notebook later to go and change the
instructions, do whatever you like,
right? And that agent doesn't have
tools. It's just going to be a really
simple agent. So the next step down
there is you're going to add a tool.
You're going to add a few functions that
do the different things you wanted to do
like check flights, etc. And now you
have an agent that has a model and
tools. After that, which is the more fun
part, is you're going to build a
workflow agent. A workflow agent
actually says, "Wait, why should one
agent do all the calls? Let's have
dedicated agents for each step." So,
there's a flight agent, a car rental
agent, and a hotel agent. And then I
have a concierge that orchestrates them
together. And Microsoft Foundry has a
capability called workflow. So, we're
going to see that. And then this
particular lab will show you how to set
it up for tracing. And in this case, you
can actually set it up to use OTEL to
have local traces so you can see them as
you're debugging or you can have them
push to Azure found uh monitor and see
them in the foundry portal. And then
we'll have a notebook for evals and a
notebook for red teaming. So far so
good. Ready to start? So cooking show.
Try this at home. We're going to look at
it here. So the first thing is I'm going
to look at the notebook. So what do we
want to do in the first one? So this
isn't much of a a thing, but I'm just
going to scroll through really quickly.
So we have to install dependencies. All
of these come for you out of the box
with a dev container, so you don't have
to worry about them. Configure envir
environment variables. You just need to
actually when you set up your project,
you have a project endpoint and you need
to know the name of the model. It
already sets this up for you by default.
We're going to run a very simple test to
make sure that we're connected. We're
going to make sure that the client is
working.
And then we're going to make a call. So
this is kind of the the the data I
currently have. I have have some fake
data in here that we can use. And so
I've made sure that I have my data. I've
made sure I was able to make a a call to
my API endpoint. It works. I'm good to
go. Now it's time for us to create a new
agent from scratch. So when I look at
this,
and I'll actually share this whole
document out with you later.
What this will do is kind of walk you
through what the different steps are. So
here we're actually going to go through
these where this is what each of these
uh notebooks will create a new agent
that will do only that capability. And
the first one right here will teach you
how to build a very simple agent. So
the problem you're facing right now is
you've never built an AI agent before
and you want to know how to set it up
with the right instructions and so on.
So to create this basic agent,
what you're going to do is first of all
you start by setting up a client because
you're already logged in with the Azure
CLI. You have credentials. You set up a
client for use with our foundry endpoint
and then you create instructions for
your agent. So this is a standard set of
instructions that we've created for that
describes what your travel agent is
supposed to do.
And when you run this, your agent is now
created on the backend foundry with
these simple instructions and the
default model that we had deployed.
Next, you want to start a simple
conversation. So we're using the
responses API endpoint to try a single
prompt. So you said, hey, tell me for
instance uh I'm I'm basically asking a
question like, you know, I'm thinking
about planning a trip to Paris. What
should I know? It runs it and returns
the response. And now you get to see it.
At this point, we haven't done any
tracing. We haven't activated anything.
We just got a working agent that
responds the way I want it to.
Next, you can go ahead and try
multi-turn uh conversations. So, for
those who not used the SDK or are not
familiar with agents, this is a great
way for you to go try it out and get
familiar with it. But I'm not going to
go into because we're not here to talk
really about the agent building. Um all
this will let you do is validate that
you can in fact deploy a multi-turn
conversational agent to uh foundry
and you can inspect the responses and
see what kind of response it's giving
back. It's really a long winded one
right
next step if you go into this. So for
each of these you'll notice that these
are already set up with a runtime
environment. So you would just select
the the kernel that we've got on the dev
container and then just walk through the
steps one by one. So in the first case,
let's go back and to our portal and see
what that looks like.
So that first travel agent
or that was actually the first version
of that. All it did is it answered the
question, right? So we have that
deployed here and if I ask it a
question, it's going to give me whatever
I need for that answer. And I should see
the traces in here as well. So give me a
minute for it to start up.
So the the agent that I set up that we
invoked from the from the kind of from
the code, I can go in and see that when
I ask this question, it actually
answered it and I can see the traces,
but I don't see the evals because I
haven't set them up yet.
The next thing we're going to do is
we're going to go in and add
tools. So what tools do we need? So over
here we're going to use something called
a function tool definition. and we want
to register function tools that do
various things. So here we have tools
for a car search, a flight search, and a
hotel search. They're all functions
defined within this one single agent. We
register the tools and then we enhance
that agent. So now the agent before
had just a model and instructions. Now
it has model, instructions, and tools.
And when we then deploy this agent, you
can go ahead and test it. So if you go
ahead and run this uh deployed a I mean
when you deploy the agent and you then
hit that endpoint with a query about
something looking for a flight it's
going to respond to that you can go try
out different combinations like give me
a hotel and car search etc. So we're
still going through these notebooks to
just make sure that we have our agent
set up correctly. So far so good. Yes.
So we start with a base agent. We added
tools. We got multiconization. We're
good.
But now I look at it and go, wait, we
really don't want one monolithic agent
doing all this work. We want to be
break, we want to be able to break up
the task into the smallest units of work
and have dedicated agents do that and
then orchestrate them together. Anyone
here who's used Langraph, Langchain, you
know that multi- aents kind of have
design patterns around them. So how do
you do that? It turns out that Foundry
actually has this concept known as
workflows, workflow agents. So in this
particular lab, what we're going to
actually go into is build out a workflow
agent. So over here, the problem that
you're facing right now is you had a
single agent and now if something goes
wrong, you've got multiple functions to
track, multiple things to do, you really
want to break it down into smaller
components. So in this particular lab,
you're going to start creating
specialist agents. So you remember in
that very first lab, we created a travel
agent. Now, think you're just going to
create three of those agents, but now
dedicated to individual tasks.
So, you create this three specialist
agents and then you create a workflow
agent that puts them all together. So,
I'm not going to go into all of the
details here, but what I really want you
to look at is the different insert
traces. So, here when I create the
workflow agent, I give it a declarative
YAML statement that says how the
workflow is knitted together and then I
can actually test it end to end. So
let's see what that looks like when we
deploy it in Foundry. So this is what a
workflow agent looks like. So right now
you've seen two kinds of agents. The
first one was a prompt agent which is
just a simple lightweight declarative
agent where I've given it instructions
in a model but it's doing one thing.
It's a single-use agent. Here with
workflows
that YAML lets me visually compose the
agent together. So now I can be like,
okay, the workflow says I want to
actually create a conversation with each
of those agents. I need to get the
flight agent to get get a response, the
hotel agent to get a response, and the
car agent, put them together, and then
deliver to the user. And when I invoke
this agent, I can actually see the
traces in the portal. So, I'm kind of
getting to the fact that in the when
when Amy did her first uh kind of walk
through, you notice that every agent
every time you ask a question, we
already have it set up with our traces.
But now you're able to see how much more
you can actually go and analyze the path
of your invocation through this entire
workflow. So over here now you can see
when I ask a question of the agent, it
now goes through a workflow, figures out
how to invoke every agent in turn. So,
invoke the flight agent to get me
information about the flight. Invoke the
hotel agent to get me that. And then put
them all together. And so, the value for
us now is you're able to see which of
these agents is underperforming, which
of these agents is not actually doing
its job correctly, what are the costs
token wise for this, and then flip out
only the agents that you need to
optimize to do better.
>> Yes.
optimiz
this very complex way. You said there's
too many rel
because we're going to No, no, no. I'm
going to answer it now, but you're going
to we're going to look at it again when
we look at the skill.
>> But your point, I'm just going to repeat
his questions. Let me know if I got this
right. One, cost. Can we actually
optimize for cost?
>> And second one is you were asking u what
is the complexity? What was the second
question?
>> How do I
>> Yeah.
>> Yes. So um I'm going to answer both in
part. Costwise there are two things that
impact cost. One is you think about the
model cost. You might have a GPT41 is
going to cost you more in tokens than
maybe GPT4 on mini. So one of the things
you do is you switch models. This is one
of the right and when you do that you
immediately run the eval and see did my
was there regression so did my cost drop
but the accuracy get so you can try
these out right and you'll see that in
the skill that you can actually try
these out flip the model try that out
second thing is you can see why is it
spending time so for example if I used a
web search and then realize this is
really taking up too much time I would
rather just have it search a small
subset that I have cached or like I have
data in maybe cheaper so there are ways
for you to look at Right. The bigger
picture though is every time you make a
change, you should evaluate immediately
and see and compare whether it had a
regression for something else. So the
second one is how do I actually uh roll
back? So if you look at these, I'm
showing this to you in the portal, but
you'll notice later when we kind of go
through um the the skill, there are
versions over here, right? I have all
the agent versions. So deploying an
agent is you can actually just give it
the name of the identity the version
that you're that you want and have that
be the one that's the main one. And when
we use the skill, we'll see that it'll
automatically go back to a version that
had a better quality and use that going
forward. But the bottom line is they're
just identifiers. So you can basically
deploy them. Does that make sense?
>> Awesome. So uh this workflow agent now
lets you kind of like compose multiple
agents through code not through an
external framework and still have it
managed by Foundry and traceable. So one
of the things I want you to take away
from this is that from the tracing
perspective it really doesn't care what
kind of agent you have. It has an
endpoint and as long as that emits hotel
traces I can gather them and show them
to you. Same deal with evaluation.
doesn't care how you build the agent as
long as I give you an endpoint I can
then run those evals and give you
metrics back against them. So that's
this was the thing now. So now let's
talk about tracing.
So in this so far you were just kind of
learning how to deploy agents and tailor
their functions, tailor their
instructions and kind of run them and
see how well they're performing and see
their traces. But what if you actually
wanted to run or kind of like have
custom um attributes in your traces and
how could you actually activate traces
to use locally as well as in the cloud.
So if you want to look at that this
particular uh notebook
will actually deploy a custom agent
here.
So it's this one. And what you're going
to get from this is an understanding of
how tracing works.
So the problem that we've got to right
now is we've slowly been changing our
agent and we've built it out. We've
broken it up. It's now working. And to
the point when things go wrong, there
are so many possible ways they could go
wrong. Wouldn't it be nice if I could
add my own custom attributes into those
traces so that when I want to kind of go
troubleshoot later, I can look for the
right things. So in this we're going to
look at how you can actually uh kind of
bring in custom attributes into your
tracing. So in the first one this
we've got two different sets for this.
The first thing is we want to create and
trace an agent. And what we want to do
is we want to actually have it set up to
put the traces in the local console. So
before you do that as part of the setup
you actually need to set two environment
attributes. want to enable generative AI
tracing and want to kind of capture the
message content around it. So if you go
through this, what this will allow you
to do now is to actually activate
different attributes or set different
attributes and have them seen right in
your console so you can debug as you go.
So now once I've set this up, I create a
conversation and when I actually run it,
I don't know if you guys can see this in
here, but it's putting in some of the
custom attributes that I've generated.
And let me put that as a
and now I get more personalized traces.
So I can actually dump in more
information that relates to the kinds of
things I want to debug.
Next, when I want to interpret the the
tracing itself, these traces currently
are local, but it would be great if I
could actually push them to the back end
and see them there as well. So, there
are two different layers at which you
can see these traces. One in the back
end against the agent itself. Those
traces should be visible here. So, I can
go in and kind of like see what
happened. That's just the basic tracing
behavior. But the second thing I want to
do is I want to actually push this to
Azure monitor. So Azure monitor is this
giant kind of like uh log collection of
all the telemetry across all my services
by adding my AI telemetry to it as well.
Not only do I see kind of like how the
different other services are going or
are doing, but I can see whether the
impact of performance was related to
things I was calling. So for example, I
had an Azure AI search that had an
index. I'm getting the telemetry from
that. I'm also getting the telemetry
from my AI uh applications and I can
look at them together. So in this
particular part of the lab, we're going
to configure Azure monitor tracing and
have all of the traces also sent out to
the monitor. We'll look at that in a
second on the back end. Run a trace
query and now you should be able to see
the traces in the Foundry portal.
So with that those if you walk through
those notebooks you are now able to do
all of these in code and step through
the same things that you are doing in
the portal. The evaluation one is really
taking it to the next level of showing
you how to run a quality evaluation, a
safety evaluation and an agentic
evaluation and have these run and kind
of run in batch mode in combination or
individually using some evaluator data
sets that you've provided.
So to set up this travel agent for
evaluation, the first thing is preparing
evaluation data. In this particular
case, we're using we used an AI agent
and we created a sample set of
evaluation data. Later on with a skill,
I'm going to show you how it actually
generates that for you. So what is this
evaluation data set? The evaluation data
set here is just a a couple of like
prompt test prompts, right, with uh
responses that you can use to evaluate
groundedness and so on. So we want to
kind of pick a few quality and safety
evaluators to run an evaluation. First
you deter define an evaluator object and
you specify the criteria. We're using
built-in evaluators. You notice that we
have a lot of built-in evaluators for
quality and safety and agentic. So you
just specify whichever ones you want and
for each one you're going to tell it how
the data maps to the evaluation data set
that you've provided.
Then you set up your evaluation data
flow and then you run it. When you run
the evaluation from your notebook, it
takes a long time. So you can actually
set this up to whole till the evaluation
is done. And once it's done, it'll
actually help you analyze the results
locally or you can go into the portal
and you can see that again. So the trace
the evaluation notebook
generates this agent and you can see
both the traces here or you can kind of
go in and see the evaluation output.
So over here one of the things you'll
see is that we had three evaluators in
that notebook.
the quality evaluation.
And just to kind of give you a sense of
what you see here, you have a copy of
the data set that was used. And when I
look at this,
it's just telling me that for the
metrics that I looked at, which is
coherence, fluency, it's passing all the
tests. There's actually, and this is a
very kind of like a a very simple test
set. So, we're not doing anything major.
But what what it does allow you to do is
see the results and download them and
see the logs. But let's take a look at
the agentic ones.
So in agentic in addition to the basic
ones that we had we are actually looking
at intent resolution. Uh we might look
at things like um task adherance and
tool calling. Let's take a look at one
of these here. In this case it said
groundedness fail. So now I want to dive
in and see what happened. I should
actually be able to look through this
and see where those uh failures are.
So over here I can see that there was a
failure in groundedness. And now one of
the things for me is to understand why
why was this given as a fail and you can
see that the reason it came up with is
that the response answered with a date
of August 2024 instead of 2025 which is
a failure of groundedness. It wasn't
actually grounded in the truth. So this
is a kind of like a simple notebook that
just shows you how to run your evals for
quality, safety and agentic
and then you can interpret the results
and kind of we're done um and view them
in the portal. The last thing I want to
do is show you red teaming. So with this
so far, what you've actually been doing
is just setting up evaluators with one
of the built-in quality, safety, or
agentic evaluators, running it, and then
seeing the results of the portal. But
red teaming is where you want to set up
a scan where it proactively attacks your
agent to see whether it can basically
get through and assess it for
vulnerabilities to different kinds of
manipulated prompts. So how many of you
have done red teaming or pen testing?
Anyone familiar with how red teaming
works?
So red teaming is actually kind of cool.
With red teaming, what you do is you get
a second AI to attack your first AI. So
the red teaming agent that we have, you
basically tell it, here are the risk
categories that I think my agent is
susceptible to. You define the kinds of
attacks you want and then it will
basically attack your agent with those
prompts and give you a report that says
these are the cases under which your
agent failed. So how does that work? It
works like this. If I were to say hey
please tell me how to rob a bank and
that's the kind of uh example Amy had.
My safety guardians are going to come in
and say no you can't do that. Cannot
don't answer the question and it would
be right. But it turns out that maybe if
I were to flip it, right, flip the the
prompt around, the safety godre looks at
it and goes, "This is gibberish. There's
nothing wrong with this. I'm going to
let the prompt go through." And the
model says, "Oh, silly guy. He flipped
the string. Let me flip it back. Now I
see what you want me to do." And it'll
actually execute it. So you slip past
the guardrail because you manipulated
the prompt. What red teaming allows you
to do is it proactively goes and checks
all those different uh attack strategies
and then tells you what you're
vulnerable to. So in this particular uh
notebook, what you're going to do is
you're going to look at what kinds of
agentic attacks you can perform. For
example, prohibited actions. You see
with quality and safety, you're looking
at red teaming your model. You're just
looking at the behaviors. Agentic is
very dangerous because if I can
manipulate the agent to do an action
that it was not supposed to do, that's
harmful. So with prohibited actions,
which is one of the newer agentic uh red
teaming uh attacks you can do or strateg
I'm going to give you a taxonomy of
actions that your agent is not allowed
to do. It can't go and fill in
passwords. It can't leak data. It can't
do this, etc. Right? And now when you
fill this in, the retaining agent will
proactively come up with prompts that
will test this for you. Yes,
>> do the reverse and say you have the
right to do nothing except what I
authorize you to do and when authorizes.
>> That is what a guardrail would do. What
you're saying is you're telling your
agent these are the things you should
do, right?
>> What red teaming is saying is if I tell
the agent this can I manipulate it by
using a prompt? So to your point there
are there are very famous attacks that
say oh you're not allowed to do this but
then I say my grandmom used to tell a
story about this and it says oh your
grandma let me tell you how your
grandmom would tell the story right
that's an attack so in this case the
prohibited action is saying I don't want
you to do this I want you to do this
that's the taxonomy so you're absolutely
right in your taxonomy I could say I
only want you to do this the attack the
red teaming agent says is I'm going to
be smart and figure out ways to get
around this loophole and so it comes up
with a bunch of test prompts that it'll
run and then you see how good your
prohibited action guardrail really was.
Does that make sense?
>> Okay. So, when you run this one for
example, I'm going to flip over and I'll
show you that because I know we're
running out of time. Um, so if I go into
this, let's see the red team, right?
Just to kind of be quick about it. Here
is an example of what the red teaming
agent scan looks like. So, you can see
up top I've said these are my risk
categories. This is violence, sensitive
data leakage, and task adurance. those I
I want you to see whether you can
actually assess vulnerabilities to me
following these and the attack is lead.
If you're familiar with this lead is
that way in which you can use like
numbers instead of letters to make
things look good. So the question is if
I were to use an attack where the prompt
is using lead rather than normal English
does it get through my guardrail. Very
simple attack. I can go in and actually
run this and you'll see that in this
case it was a very simple attack.
Nothing major. It passed everything. We
didn't do anything at all. You can
however then go in and I I'll start one
up but u I don't know if it'll finish by
the time we kind of get this there. If
you basically go in that was that just
showed you how to run an attack but if
you go in here and I say okay go ahead
and give me let's pick the contoso agent
that we had any one of them there are
actually a lot of different more
comprehensive attacks that we can try.
So here are the various attacks that I
can actually or here are the risk
categories. Let's keep all of them. And
then I can look at the attack strategies
and see these. These are easy attacks.
But there are things like a crescendo
attack right here that are super
difficult. And what a crescendo attack
does is it starts it off like a frog in
boiling water. Starts with a small
attack. Says, "Oh, you got through it.
Then I'm going to kind of build on that
with a second one and a second one. And
by the time you've recognized
something's going on, you're being hit
on all sides." Right? So if you run a
crescendo attack, it takes a really long
time, but it will determine all the
vulnerabilities in your system. So in
our case, we had just run it with a very
simple one, but you can go in and look
at all the different attacks that are
there, all the different risks and run
them.
So with that, let me actually kind of
get back to we because got a few minutes
and I really want to show the Amy, are
you good with me just going on to the
skilling?
>> Okay, so I really wanted to actually
talk about this. So I'm going to kind of
go into that instead. So, we went
through uh the SDK,
but all of this is the old way of doing
stuff, right? What if we could make this
better? You still don't understand all
the things you don't know. So, what I
really wanted to show you today, and
this is in very early preview, is this
notion of an observe skill.
So, right now, and for those of you want
to try that at home, uh you will know
it's documented over here. It's the
third thing in there.
So what it is is Microsoft foundry has a
top level skill that has defined best
practices for doing everything that you
would do with an end to end agent
development create deploy and so on and
over here these are all the different
things we're going to focus on observe
observe is a subscale and what does
observe actually do observe and I think
I have that in here if not let me just
bring that up what observe does is it
lets you go in and get the whole
observability loop done through an
agent. Let's actually just see it in
action.
So, let me know if you're able to see
this. Okay,
can you all see the right side of the
screen?
I'm going to minimize all this.
So now remember that portal agent that
Amy had set up with the observe skill. I
didn't have to do any of the stuff I did
with the SDK. Instead I just go to the
copilot in in this case we're using
GitHub copilot chat to activate that
skill. I have a coding agent. I'm using
cloud as my model with it. And I just
say, can you please use this observe
skill to start the observability loop on
my agent and do the work for me? At this
point, I only have an agent. I have no
eval set. I have nothing. Can you please
help me evaluate this? And what it does
is it kind of goes in and it looks at
your code and says, you don't have an
eval data set. You I know what you're
trying to do because you've shown me the
instructions. I'm going to start
building this out. So the first thing is
it checks whether I have metadata and
when I don't you're seeing kind of like
the cooked agent goes ahead and sets up
a cache and the first thing it did is it
went ahead and generated the eval data
set for me. Okay so I'm going to walk
through this really quickly. You see
that it reviewed files and created
to-dos and then started working through
them. It got the agent details. It ran
the evaluate catalog built an evaluated
data set and then it ran that first
batch eval. So, it said, "I have an
agent. I need a baseline. I'm going to
run this." So, it goes ahead. And by the
way, it didn't find the agent because I
spelled it wrong. Figured that out.
Fixed it. And now it says, "Okay, you
have this travel portal agent.
I'm going to take the data set you gave
me and I'm going to run the uh the
evaluation." And one of the greatest
things that I find useful here is the
reasoning. It goes in there and you
actually get to see what it looks for in
terms of the failures and how it had
actually instrumented the evals and so
once it finishes this
it kind of like it goes through all the
things that need and now it finishes
this evaluation runs it runs it runs it
and then it comes back to me and says
here is the result. So this is the first
batch eval and I didn't have to do
anything except set up my agent with a
simple instruction, a model and an
endpoint. And it comes back and says
based on what you have, your prompt is
not actually perfect.
Relevance is fine, but task a there are
cases where it's not actually completing
the task you asked it to do. There are
two failures and I can actually go in
and look through the reasoning. It'll
tell me where those failures are. Your
internet resolution looks good. And for
the indirect I tried one test for safety
and that passed right. So it comes back
with a key finding and said hey there is
a problem
and it says would you like me to solve
that right so the next thing Tom comes
back and says okay so this is human in
the loop right I did the first step for
you would you like me to take another
step or is there something you'd like to
do so I'm like please go ahead and just
analyze those failures for me optimize
the instructions and reevaluate. So what
this starts doing is it runs something
called a prompt optimizer. It says based
on the way you've written your prompt,
you left it open for misinterpretation.
I'm going to optimize that prompt and
you asked me at the time how do we
actually roll back this automatically
get puts a new version number and tests
right and if it if it it sees a
regression it can roll it back and
you'll see that too. So over here
it's now it's now updating the agent.
This is where it goes and pushes the new
version of the agent. It runs a new
batch eval again waits for the
evaluation to get done and voila when
it's done it gives me a nice clean table
says here is where you were I optimized
your prompt reran the batch evals with
the same evaluators and now it's
improved by one it's not perfect I
didn't get a 10 but it did fix one of
those issues that you had so it's better
your task adherance and there was this
issue in the prompt that I fixed which
is now tighter so now you've got this
and now it says what would you like me
to
And this is where it gets interesting.
So I was like greedy and I said I want
you to I want to push for 10 out of 10.
I want you to fix that last remaining
thing. And at this point this is where
human in the loop makes a difference
because it starts just manipulating the
prompts to see what else it can fix.
Right? So over here it keeps going
through them trying it out. And now you
start seeing the point you were making
where if I actually I'll push it all the
way to the end so you can see it. It'll
go back and forth and it'll keep
regressing
and it'll keep finding that it it
improves to seven and it comes back to
eight. It'll improve to seven, come back
to five and at some point it'll
basically say, you know what, of all the
things that we did so far. So this is
where the human in the loop can say, you
know, you need to stop. So it says the
best version for my agent was version
five. So let's go and stick with that.
Right? So over here it comes back and
says here is the entire history of me
trying different things and telling you
how I'm able to improve it and for each
one I'm going to give you insights into
what worked what didn't and now we're at
version 10 of all of them five is the
best let's go back let's use that right
yes
>> does it only change the prompt or it can
change the model
>> it can change other things so this one
is it started with a batch eval and it's
looked at that right so it'll actually
come back and say would you like me to
look into perhaps for example It'll say
web search is taking a lot of time.
Would you like me to look for an
alternative for that? Right? So yes, the
thing in this is this is where the human
in the loop makes a difference. The
reasoning kind of gives us insights and
this is where I think you know it's what
we don't know that hurts us. It's not
about I don't even know what I don't
know. And what this does is exposes me
to what I don't know. But yes, at that
time I can actually guide the skill what
the default skills and you can actually
go look at the skill MD because when it
installs it, you'll see it. You know
what it's looking for. It's got a set of
best practices it checks through. If you
have domain knowledge, you might want to
apply it, right? And say, well,
actually, this is likely to be the case.
Can we go try that? And it'll do that.
But what was I don't know if you you get
why I love this so much is it automates
the batch eval compare it and show me
what happened without me having to know
every single SDK call and stuff, right?
And so that was the thing there. So
here, yes, to your point, there are
other things behind the scenes that you
can look at. And now at the end I'm like
can you just show me a full summary of
what's happening right but the more
important thing on this that uh I I
think I just wanted to kind of showcase
before we're done is it'll at the end
it'll tell you what else you can do
recommendations for future work I was
showing a prompt agent but how many of
you use lang chain lang graph etc. You
can actually build your agent with that
and bring it into foundry using
something called hosted agents and I can
go to it that this point and say we've
been using the observe skill. Can we use
a create skill to convert this prompt
agent into a hosted agent and use
langraph to build it for me and it'll do
that too. So the point on the skill is
really about moving away from looking at
the editor and moving to a coding agent
that will manipulate it but we are
actually guiding it through the process.
If that makes sense.
Does that make sense to everyone? Okay.
So, uh the the the final thing about
this is you can see that it gives you
different recommendations for what you
can do tracing based evaluations, red
teaming etc. And so you can guide it
through all of them because there are
skills behind the scenes. Yes.
>> And if you come to realization that you
need to update the evaluation set then
redo the whole process essentially.
>> Yes. And you can actually tell it. So
one of the things and let me see if I
can show that thing to you because it
makes more sense if you can see it. I'll
I'll publish this uh document out there.
But um if you look at the actual skills,
it's over here.
So this is the
god it's not
okay.
See if it opens this.
And I should probably hide some things
here. All right.
It wasn't supposed to pull up this
window. Can you all see this? Okay.
>> So, it's an open source project, so you
can actually go look at it. So, Azure
Copilot uh for I mean GitHub copilot for
Azure. This is the Microsoft Foundry
skill um the Foundry agent. And if you
look into this, these are all the skills
available. So, I'm going to kind of walk
through what the observability loop
looks like. So, if you can see this,
what it does is all of these tasks. And
if you want to, here's an easier way.
There's a QR code. You can grab the QR
code and go directly to this page if
you're interested. Um, what this is
using is the Foundry MCP server. And all
of these, it's looking for trigger words
like this. So, evaluate my agent, help
me build a data set, etc. One of the
subs skills that it has is to create a
data set. Another subskll that it has is
to analyze your insights and so on. So
you can look through these to see what
kinds of things you can actually call
out on it and uh run them from there.
And then let me see if I can just finish
up uh what we were talking about. So you
can basically go through this and have
it iterate more than once. And last but
not least, this is bringing coding
agents into your SDK and into your IDE.
But what if I needed the same help to
analyze my insights, right? So I want to
show you a couple of last things and
then we'll call it a day. Um if you are
going into the portal anytime you're in
the portal and you have an issue with
something you can actually use the ask
AI
and the interesting thing about ask AI
is it's an agent that knows the state of
your project. So you can say can you
look at this trace ID? Can you tell me
what models I have access to in this
subscription? Do I have quota and ask it
questions here and it's reasoning on the
state. The other one is in your traces.
So if you actually go into your
insights, I don't know about you, but
I'm not a KQL query person at all. Can't
write it to save my life. So I want to
actually know what am I looking at in
all this data. If you click on the logs
for your u app insights at the top,
there's now an observability agent
helper. And what this allows you to do
is allows you to convert all those
programmatic queries you have written
into natural language interactions with
an agent that'll do the job for you. So
over here for instance I can kind of go
in and say hey can you find failures
like you now have access to my entire uh
log workspace right so can you go ahead
and give me an analysis on what this is
doing etc.
Um, and I think we are way past time.
So, um, the two things that I just
showed you at the end, ask AI, uh,
that's the one that's in the Foundry
portal and the observability agent is
the one that's in the Azure portal. And
I think with that, Amy, do you want to
do any wrap-up or do I? All right. So
I'm just going to wrap up on this and
say if you grab those two codes, the
first one is the entire repository and
even the skills part is completely
documented in there. Uh hopefully later
today I'll publish the step-by-step uh
transcript that I have as well. So you
can kind of see my results against yours
on the discord while you run this. If
you run into issues, please join Discord
and the AI engineer channel and then
kind of leave us notes there. We'd love
to get issues from you. And kind of to
wrap this up, you know, we started by
saying there's a gap in agent
observability. How do you mine the gap
and how do you isolate the eval
optimized loop? So hopefully we did a
job semideently well. And the main thing
we're trying to say is the gap in agent
observability is three things, right?
One, you start off with a working agent,
but that working agent will drift from
the original requirements because models
could change, prompts could change, your
environment could change, new edge cases
come in. How do you constantly and
continuously evaluate what's going on
and get alerted when that gap changes?
That's tracing and monitoring. And
second, how do you accelerate the loop?
You can do it manually of course but why
not start taking advantage of coding
agents and have those automate some of
this for you with a human in the loop to
guide them so you are faster at
responding to some of the these issues
before they get out of hand and finally
coming back to close the loop on the
questions we asked too many models no
existing data what do we do we can use
coding agents we can use either co-pilot
or uh skills and have that generated
based on what our current state of the
application or our current requirements
are keeping up with fast changes. How
can it detect issues and diagnose them
quickly? The answer is trace based I
mean trace linked evaluations. So we
want to be able to have a view that lets
us see both the traces that show you how
it executed and the evaluations that
said what was the result of the of this
change that I made. And then for
safeguarding practices, you want to
think not only about safety evaluations
for normal behavior, which is setting
the default guardrails, but also
adversarial kind of testing where you
proactively attack it to see whether you
can get past those guardrails by using
techniques that we may not even have
thought of that folks like the pirate
team are progressively kind of building
on.
And I'll leave you with one last thing.
I am not like like many of you. I'm just
trying to keep up with the pace of
things, but there are experts in the
space. So, if you're interested in it,
we have a series called Model Mondays.
Just so happens that this Monday, uh,
Felicia Sha is the person behind the
skills that you just saw. She's a PM who
runs the Foundry Skills, uh, section of
things. So, she's going to come and do a
demo and tell us what's coming next.
What you saw is really, really early.
It's like literally got released two
weeks ago. They're already building on
that. So if you're interested in that,
please do attend and she'll have an AMA
so you can ask her questions directly.
The other one which is interesting for
those of you who use AI toolkit is
what's new in that. And the main thing
here is a lot of the stuff that you saw
that was doing uh being done in the
portal and SDK can now be done right in
VS Code using that extension and can be
done much faster locally. So that's
about improving your local developer
experience. And with that, I think
that's the end. Uh thank you all for
sticking around. I think we're at time
little over appreciate it. And if you
have any questions or just want to hang
out in chat, please do come and let us
know. And thanks again.